to spend some time for a program so okay
so this is uh doing to work with Maya
Alex and Omer and I'm going to talk
about snarks Beyond no signaling so okay
yesterday supposedly you heard a lot
about snarg so hopefully most of you
know uh what they are so just one you
know minute of refresher so in a snark
you have some computation M and input X
you want to compute an output Y and you
want to have a certificate a succinct
certificate that certifies the
correctness of the computation uh to do
that usually we assume that the both the
person issuing the certificate and the
verifier the verifies it share some
common random string and we have kind of
the usual completeness and soundness
requirements namely uh if you did the
computation correctly then you should be
able to efficiently generate a
certificate that verifies and
importantly the certificate should be
very succinct and so the time to so if
the computation is T times take T time
the com the certificate should be much
smaller than T and verifying it should
take much smaller than T otherwise
there's not no point in Outsourcing this
computation
and uh the soundness is a computational
soundness which says that it should be
hard computationally hard to generate a
fake certificate namely to generate a
certificate for an incorrect A outcome
and what I mean by hard I want to say
it's if you could do it then you could
break some cryptographic assumption
okay this was extremely fast but I
assume you guys are familiar yeah okay
so by the way is there if if there are
any questions
let me know yeah okay so constructions
so you know there's been in the last
decade uh just an unbelievable the
amount of work that's been done in this
field
no no there's more sorry it is it's uh
yeah
uh much more as you'll see and as
inferred yesterday hey so a lot of this
results there's a theoretic Appliance
and so forth the focus of this talk is
on on the theoretical side namely
constructing snargs that are provably
secure under standard cryptographic
assumptions that's our goal that's what
we're after
okay
so here's kind of the blueprint that we
have yes
oh no no not for p y p no no p and
beyond for NP actually that's what we
want to do yeah
no restrictions so here's the blueprint
that we have that we know of for
constructing these nouns okay and this
started with the joint work with the
Iran Raku and with one rod so here's the
blueprint the idea is the following
first using cryptography to construct
not a really sound proof but what we
called a quasi argument it's quasi-sound
what does that mean it means I don't
offer soundness really but I promise you
the guarantee is that given a Hoover who
can convince me I can use him to
generate kind of uh local consistency
not Global correctness but rather local
consistency let me tell you what this
means what this means is let's say I
want to put you some table over
computation this is table over
computation what we can you do is take
the guarantee is that you can take a
cheating proofer and use him to kind of
for every few locations locals for any
pure location the Tableau he will give
you can use them to generate an
assignment to these locations and this
assignment locally will be consistent
so I can ask him these locations let's
say there's a gate satisfied I can ask
from these locations they'll give me or
use them to generate values for these
locations that the blow they'll be
consistent and importantly it has this
non-signaling property that if I ask him
you know the middle one that was asked
twice the distribution and the answer he
gives me is the same so the distribution
I get that I get from him and this
element is the same whether it was F
with a yellow or whether it was asked
with the red okay so I can use the
prover to get local consistency
everywhere on the Tableau I can ask use
the proofer to get assignment for any
subset of locations the Tableau there
are some local consistent and for each
kind of subset of the location the
distribution that he gives me is
independent of the rest of the questions
okay so that's kind of the first part
this local consistency
and then there's kind of a generic way
to argue to if you have local
consistency it implies Global
correctness
that's the blueprint
all the results we know essentially
Loosely speaking follows almost all
results follow this blueprint
and this part is just information
theoretics
okay and the first part is the crypto
one
so one way we can do this part is just
doing a what's called hash and barg
batch argument which again I assume uh
you've all heard about yesterday so the
idea is use a hash that's somewhere
extractable so I'm going to ask the
prover okay put an assignment everything
on the Tableau assign values to everyone
so essentially compute the entire
Tableau hash it down
using a locally uh extractable hand so I
can extract a few locations and then
give me a bar a batch argument that all
the gates are satisfied
and now we can argue that because all
the gates are satisfied we have kind of
this local consistency uh requirement
and the size of the session book depends
on the locality so I said you get local
consistency we can choose how local we
want to be the locality can be very
small the locality can be big and big
locality will help the local Global
guarantee but will suffer in the size of
the actual snug we get
foreign
the blueprint that we have today for
constructing snugs
okay
so first thing you can ask so I said you
know you can go from local to Global
this is information theoretics at first
one can think that oh going from local
correctness to Global should be driven
trivial and therefore we can you know so
you know once we have this local we're
done okay it's not the case it's really
not the case that's where all the
problem is but let me try to convert to
let's see why why isn't that not trivial
so suppose you give me local correct
local consistency okay so I got the
first part it's locally consistent it's
good it's correct I get the second part
it's correct so now these two are
correct so the third is correct
sorry until I get to the end in the end
would be correct
kind of when we started thinking about
this uh you know 10 years ago this is
what we thought and this should work it
doesn't
okay this local the global is a real
pain and so let me tell you why why one
reason it doesn't work one issue is that
actually the bark the hashenberg I said
it guarantees local consistency or local
correctness it doesn't it guarantees it
with probability one minus some
negligible air because above we know
when once used crypto there's always
negligible kind of uh probability of
error
so the local consistency is given it
only is probably one minus negligible
okay but now at some small it's
negligible okay so this is let's say
correct with all but negligible at some
probability okay the problem is
for this to be correct two things need
to be correct it's like think of it as
an and
so now the when you go up the player
you're correct with all but too Epsilon
because it's enough that one of the
previous things were incorrect to ruin
to ruin it for you
and when you go up the level you've got
four uh essentially you'll get two to
the depth blow up in air
and this kind of exponential blow up
kills us
okay so this kind of shows even for p
even if you're only concerned with P
this kind of local to Global does not
work as is
okay of course even for for MP
everything I said now makes no sense
because what does it mean correct there
is no correct it depends on the witness
and what can happen is maybe you know uh
let's say this is consistent with one
witness this is consistent with another
witness now you add them together then
nothing makes sense
so when you talk about NP or
non-deterministic kind of computations
this local the global becomes a real
nightmare
okay so this is kind of uh a big problem
nevertheless kind of the most of the
work we did kind of in the setting is
exactly on trying to go from local to
Global and often it require kind of
being creative with with this step
okay so how how did we do it so a
okay so for example in the original work
we talked only about a bounded space
computations and we said let's be kind
of extractable or the local will contain
an entire kind of uh a configuration
or an entire layer or even two layers
and then kind of the idea is this way we
won't uh we won't suffer the exponential
curse because now we know okay local
consistency promises all of this is
cracked and now we'll read these two
because all of this is correct and we
have local consistency all of this is
correct and every time we just lose one
Epsilon as opposed to doubling
so that's one way to do it for bounded
space deterministic computation because
you talked about correctness
until you go on top
this one later we were able to show it
for also
non-deterministic uh bounded space
computations I don't want to go into it
because I need to short my talk a bit
but essentially the idea was very
similar to before but now instead of
talking about correctness because
correctness doesn't make sense of the
non-deterministic settings we talk about
kind of an ocean of reachability is this
layer reachable from the input or not is
there any witness that will bring you up
here or not so it's kind of a different
notion
and but a similar argument
and also we managed to go beyond the the
bounded to all deterministic to all for
determinism for all computations without
any restriction on the space
and that actually the way we avoided
this kind of exponential curse that I
talked about was using a kind of uh some
encoding of the Tableau and we needed to
encode the Tablo in a way that even if
you read a little part of a layer
it kind of you can infer that you know
you can infer the entire correctness of
an entire layer so
I heard some encoding low degree
extension type encoding for those of
familiar but I don't want to go into it
I point I want to make is that you know
even though it seems like local to
Global ahead of time should be easy
actually dealing with it is is a bit of
a pain okay and we don't know how to do
it in general
and importantly what I want to focus is
all these computations for which we
managed to argue that local correct
local consistency applies Global
correctness there are these computations
have what is called a non-singling PCP
so I don't want to Define what an answer
in PCP is it's a notion that was
motivated by Quantum uh but what uh the
point I want to make is not taking PCP
is a restriction for example not all of
NP
or we believe that not not all of NP has
a nonsense PCP with with a few queries
okay with the local magazine PCP so I
guess the point is all these have a
nonsense in PCP and this is restrictive
okay this already shows you you're stuck
with uh kind of in for you're stuck with
languages that have Nancy pcps which is
not everything
so you won't be able to show to argue
let's say snog for NP using this
template
yeah
good good yes good so lali's question
was do we have a snarg for all languages
that have 19 PCP and the answer is yes
yes almost with some statistical
computational version of natural PCP but
close enough yeah so we have that and
we're stuck with that essentially
okay
other questions
This Is The Answer Lali that's the best
questions man you know so uh yeah so
we're stuck really if and only if we
have another single PCP with this
framework
okay
can we do better
so first of all the answer is well if
you were willing to assume IO we know we
can do our indistinguishable obfuscation
we know we can do all of NP we have
snobs for NP assuming indistinguishable
obfuscation
so
oh well there's a few issues with this
first of all it's only for non-adaptive
soundness so it's not really you need to
decide what your instance is before
you're given the CRS
uh also IO is not a falsifiable a
assumption uh
uh even though in recent work uh by Jane
by Jane and Jin they showed they've
invented it for some subclass specific
subclass uh in NP interested Point P
also CRS is large there's no kind of EX
you know an objects other issues but
you know the main kind of uh issues is
that it's not also powerful and it's
unadaptive
but I want to say something about this
this their work the way they do so now
using the i o essentially it's in CRS
the common random stream they have uh
obfuscation of a circuit in this circuit
like in one shot checks the entire
computation for you you get a witness it
checks the entire thing in one track
gives you kind of a little I know
signature like a proof that if the
witness is good or not
so these two techniques are very kind of
different in different spectrum and the
the kind of the first blueprint I gave
you oh the crypto what it allows you to
do is argue very local form of
correctness
the sidewalkers uh snark what allows you
to do is if you have a witness you plug
it into the scene you're given to the
CRS like magically up comes like a
little certificate a little uh signature
of the correctness
you're right you're right you're right
you're right but morally kind of
Okay so I want to kind of I I wanna
depart from this very local Viewpoint in
trying to get get something else from my
crypto Beyond just this logo because
this local kind of uh constraints us
hey so or in other words here's like the
question uh we were really after is can
we construct the scenario with adaptive
soundness falsifiable assumption
under poor computation that are not
known to have non signaling PCP I'm not
saying they don't but at least I don't
know how you know I I don't know they do
hey no so I don't know I I believe that
actually because
you know what actually when you go to NP
even if you go to to bags uh like
adaptivity becomes you're right you're
good to hear it's not adopted okay
because even when you've got someone
inside activity uh MP there are other
issues with uh with snogs that come up
so even you know what forget about the
adapter good that's a great thank you a
great comment yeah even without the I
wrote down because we get it but
actually this question is interesting in
the non-adaptive setting hey
did you know about concerning this
dangerous
right so in the Adaptive setting we know
you can't do it for all them people but
you may have languages so yeah so JJ
Weeks lower bound says oh you can't have
adopted snarls under fossil five awesome
options for all of them
but you may have them for some languages
that are you know don't have nonsense in
PCP so yeah
[Music]
exactly so what we're doing three weeks
tells you it's more specifically is that
if a language
is T hard you can't kind of you know if
I give you a random instance a random
functional distribution in the language
and out the language if you can't
distinguish it in time T you won't have
a snog of size less than log t
and if because there is languages that
can be exponentially hard maybe even two
to that and hard
you can't have a small size smaller than
that that's kind of what they say but we
have languages for that can be computed
maybe in time to to the end to the
Epsilon that don't have an answer to PCP
I want to snap from them of size enter
Epsilon
so yeah ideally I want to get I want to
kiss junky works okay I wanna kind of
match their lower bound with an upper
bound and the question can we do that
yeah yes you want to know the language
so you guys are really lovely questions
hey so what we show is ridiculous there
exists a snart for the class of
monitoring policy policy batch MP so let
me tell you under a standard assumption
or CRS is one so let me tell you what
this class is the class is think of uh
actually a
but here's the class the class is uh an
instance contains let's say
fix some NP language you can think of
the language as being kind of a bunch of
public keys or whatever language and now
I an instant so there's some MP language
L now and there's some policy as monoton
policy yes and now I say that x one of
the XK is in the language
I have witnesses that kind of satisfy
the policy so if there exists this is
one if and only if there's a witness for
X1 being in the language or within and
if enough of them you know if I have
enough witness that satisfy the monoton
policy then it's in the language yeah
like majority exactly threshold an
example is just threshold
okay that's a good attempt to think
about okay if you have more than two
witnesses you're in the language
I feel like you're itching to say
something
hey
you can relate
okay so right so in other words there is
a monoton uh policy F and the output is
one if you know you for each one you uh
B1 is one if it's in the language zero
otherwise and you it's in delay it's uh
this this x's and the language of the
output is one do you care about the
complexity of this
uh yeah I um so you should think about
that opposed I mean
not really but I usually would think
about his polynomial because original
one thing of the Proverbs problem so
when I say it yeah I don't care if I
know but it could be you know it doesn't
have a polynomial inside
no I want to think of it as having
amount of time I think I think of it as
having a polynomial size
I think that that's the mindset you
should be in I we can you can generalize
it I don't think we're using it but
that's kind of the how we should think
about it yeah
exactly good so it right so if F was
bounded space we can use it we can use
prior results
a
thank you
I'm trying to you know adaptively Skip
so
based on a a okay yeah there's some
there's a parameters but I think they're
not about uh interesting
um okay not only so uh Ron's comment was
if it was bounded space couldn't you do
it using because we have bounded space
non-deterministic snarks the answer is
yes
moreover we can also do it as the depth
is small so let me give you this is a
warm-up because it will help us
understand what's going on so
let's say suppose first that you're okay
with the snarg that grows with the deck
of the the circuit F so I have this
function f in the circuit suppose you're
okay paying the stock being as big as
the depth d d
ude why do you have a chance to do that
I mean oh to this sorry okay our our
snark here so this is a generalization
upper bar so you know yesterday about
a conjunction everything's in the
language and the size of the snog here
similar to The Snug of a bar a group of
length of one which
times and pounds so this is why you're
right if it was smaller than one witness
you would be it would be impossible yeah
so this is you can think it's just
generalization of bugs what is M here m
is one witness sorry m is the links of
one one released
okay and we prove this we get this not
assuming essentially about we use about
to construct this so essentially say if
you have a bound you can generalize it
to any monoton a foreign
policy not have
not signaling PCP oh okay we don't know
that it has
and it doesn't but we don't know that it
has
and I'll explain to you why in a minute
you know maybe okay uh
no let me take it offline we don't know
that it has yeah
yeah so okay the question was a
conjunction and the answer is yes and
I'll explain action with the depth why
actually the depth is if you're willing
to go with the debt
you have an absolute PCP with locality
that goes with adapters
and that's why conjunction has because
conjunction has a very small company you
can you can reproduce the can you
reproduce the bark result by saying oh
here's a non-signal in PCP let's just
apply our
verifiable
so the the point here is that there's
there's languages that don't have uh
like uh there's this outline saying
construct a no signal PCP convert it
into uh and it's not it's not
right using coupons now we have a class
of languages right that is just uh um
like a conjunction of uh
languages or right right instances
um and uh my question and for this we
actually know what it is we saw these
constructions of bugs yeah yeah yeah but
you cannot cast these constructions as
saying first construct first have a no
signal no no no no no no no no of course
not no no I don't know how to have an
example
I don't know how to construct I'm not
saying it's easy to construct a barg if
you give me an Instagram PCP but all I'm
saying is the the conjunction of empty
Witnesses it does have an awesome
it has it does have an awesome gcp
actually our work on on barbs in the
non-adaptive settings and
the private verifiable setting
right we had bugs in the primary care
private setting we started from 19 PCP
so Barb I mean uh a conjunction
the conjunction when P it does have an
antonym
I'm not saying it's easy given us to
construct valves I'm not saying that you
know the way the way uh cjj constructive
Barnes was not by a necessarily
construct you know not it's not trivial
giving an answer to PCB that's for sure
not the construction is out there to me
they're totally different but it does
have a 19 piece that way which has a 19
PCP so all our snobs personally are for
languages that are non-demnational PCP
that's different than saying they've
given nothing basically it's easy to
construct them okay great okay
so let me first show you as a warm-up
how to construct s for these monoton
batch and P
ee uh where you're okay with this not
growing with the depth it will just kind
of help us a little bit so the idea
let's do exactly from the previous
Paradigm the hash and bark Paradigm to
get local consistency and then go to
Global consistency
so that's what we do okay and how do we
go so we get local consistency and we go
to Global cons to Global correctness
and we pay so how does it work we say
you know there so each one there's the
kind of the real bit that is it in the
language is it not in the language
and now the local my locality will be
kind of let's say in one and I'll read
an entire thing and it will be locally
consistent so correct so each little
kind of circuit that checks validity of
one witness
will be correct
and so the probability that I'll have
here a false one let's say it's supposed
to be zero it's not in the language but
I got a false one it's Epsilon it's
small because uh that's the error
guarantee and then
I'll go to Epsilon four Epsilon
eventually I'll get a false one
with probability 2D times Epsilon
exactly as before
and there's no so effectone is very very
small smaller than 2 to the minus D or
significantly smaller than
the first one
right so effect on this two to the D
times wrinkle double then the
probability of a false one is negligible
and that implies correctness because I'm
not gonna you know uh what they'll what
they'll put me here is not false not not
a false one false zero is okay it just
means they didn't prove but not a false
one
okay and indeed this thing does have an
untangling PCP with locality that is D
we know that it's kind of by by parallel
we just need to repeat it the times to
boost kind of the Epsilon and so this is
known
okay I don't want to get into exactly
but but uh and indeed I I just went
through the local to Global Paradigm so
you shouldn't be surprised I told that
this Paradigm you're stuck with
non-signal
okay so how do we depart from this
blueprint is the question and here's the
main idea
so recall the problem with this
blueprint is that we use the crypto
only to help only to guarantee local
consistency that's all we got from the
crypto the rest was information
theoretic
I want to use the crypto to get more if
that's all we get we know we're stuck
with non signaling so one I want to use
the crypto to gain more
what am I gonna get I'm gonna get local
consistency
with some Global uh predicate
so my in the Quasi argument that I in
what I'm going to get I'm going to be
able to extract
from the approver not just little kind
of local things like I'm sure are local
consistent I'm also going to be able to
extract what I want to be able to it's
some Global predicate of the entire
tableau
and I with a guarantee not only that I
have local consistency but this local
thing that I extracted is consistent
with a global predicate
so that's exactly what we do we use
crypto to get more we get local
consistency and we're able to extract a
predicate and below and we have to
guarantee that this the local
consistency is not just consistent with
its own local self it's also consistent
with the global predicate
and now
our our job here is for the information
theoretic job is easier because now I
need to argue that local consistency
that is consistent with a global
predicate
that implies Global correctness
so I I get more from the crypto and now
the information it makes information to
any part easier
so that's kind of how we depart from the
previous blue
from the previous blueprint
and recall how so how do we get this
kind of how do we use crypto to get more
so before as I said to get the Quasi
argument we used hashembark
okay and this hash is somewhere
extractable hash so you can extract from
the hatch a few locations
that was uh the the guarantee
now when we want to get a quasi argument
with global predicate extraction
instead of using a somewhat extractable
hash
we're going to use a new notion that we
call a predicate extractable hash so now
I'm not with this hash it's the same
hash local opening you can open kind of
locally fishing like a Merkel tree but
in addition
you can use a tractor to extract from
the hash value
not just some x i in the leaves but some
Global predicate and the entire input
yeah
actually this is not for monotone this
part forget about the monotone this is
think of this is a general new blueprint
I don't think that this is only relevant
for the monoton the monoton was an
example where this blueprint is used but
this is a general blueprint
okay that I I want to propose
okay
so
good so again with the some extractable
hash we can extract a bit of the input
or a few bits if we want to repeat with
a predicate extractable hash we can
extract a global predicate of the entire
input
exactly so first you can say can we do
it for any predicate right that's a good
question uh
I'll answer that in the next slide hey
but but just to say that why why this
seems like a good idea to construct is
because this uh one example is we can
avoid so I mentioned that if you know if
you're willing to pay with that with the
with the depth D you could have already
you could have gotten a song by you know
fine you you pay with exponential kind
of uh exponential in the depth and the
idea is to avoid this exponential price
by extracting a global predicate that
certifies kind of in sometimes the
correctness of an entire layer but not
really correctness not the right word
because what does it mean correctness
really what it what it certifies is
there are no false ones in an entire
layer that's what we need to we're
worried that some of the adversity
managed to put a one where it's supposed
to be zero and so we're gonna do a
predicate that kind of ensures layer by
layer that
in this layer there are no false ones
and this is in the entire layer there is
no false one then the next layer there
cannot be a false one with and because
we argued on the entire layer entire
layer of the circuit entire layer of the
circuit and because we can argue
something about the entire layer of the
circuit uh by one predicate we kind of
avoid this exponential curse because we
can circuit doesn't have to be formula
right yeah any circuit yeah any circuit
exactly exactly
yeah so I'll answer your question in the
uh so far what we at least in the paper
that we wrote where we construct a
predicate extractable hash for a
specific class of predicate the for in
particular for bit fixing predicates
we can actually do it more generally for
arbitrary kind of bounded more General
but the definition they're subtle so but
it can be generalized this is just for
an example for the specific uh result
you look as you
Yes actually yes in the actually okay
let me ask so Jeffy was saying when you
do that you know which predicate yes
moreover let me kind of let me give you
an intuition in some sense
the CRS or the hash key for the Hat
function will be an encryption of the
predicate
so when I tell you okay you you I want
you to actually put X here's your hash
key your hash key will include an
encryption of the predicate but that was
the commercially doesn't know what
happened unfortunately does not know
what that is he does not learn the
predicate but it's encrypted and now
when you compute the hash function then
reduction
of someone sort of dial where they will
see when you compute the function you
kind of compute it kind of layer by
layer and at the end you're kind of
computing the predicate in an encrypted
form for me this is very highlighted
okay for one actually we have it for
General but for
yeah you're saying the correlation yeah
yeah it does have a little bit of
actually I was thinking about it if
there's more deep
relation between the two
okay actually I say I'm out of time so
let me now get into the details but uh
essentially for those who know with some
extractable hashes you want to imitate
it the same definition everything with
predicate instead and uh so yeah uh and
okay so let me just summarize I don't
want to eat into your lunch so what what
uh we did in this work is we constructed
uh kind of we propose a new framework
for constructing snarks uh whereas the
previous framework was passion Barb uh
the what we propose what can we do is we
do a or the previous with some
extractable hash and Barb uh we propose
to do a pretty good extractable hash and
buy uh this allows us to get kind of
from the cheating prover not a quality
argument but this augmented type of
Quasi argument that has kind of a global
uh predicate extraction
and now we want to argue that this kind
of augmented quasi-argument implies
Global correctness and again this part
is information theoretic we just use the
crypto to help us get more from the
Quasi argument in the hope that it will
give us Global correctness and indeed
just uh
um and we use this to get an ultra
monoton uh batch NP I just want to
mention uh about uh money's question
that for formulas if if you restricted
the function to formulas then we do know
uh non-similarly PCP for that language
but once you allow any circuit we do not
know of an answer in PCP for that
language
so that's kind of our an example proof
of content that there's something new
here that we didn't know how to do
before we kind of broke this Paradigm
that we had before
okay so as I said this is the the I view
the monoton veteran p is just one
example for why this a this Paradigm is
useful but the hope is to use this
framework to construct snarks for other
NP computations not just for batch and p
uh for uh monotone batch and for that uh
we will need to construct a predicate
extractable hash that doesn't do is not
like for the specific bit fixing which
was the bit fitting was very important
for the specific application of monotone
batch uh more generally you probably
want some kind of to check kind of that
a layer is kind of reachable or correct
or pseudo-reachable you need some kind
of you want the predicate to kind of
commit or to extract something that says
this entire layer is good in some sense
and then for therefore the next layer is
good and what good is what we call like
pseudo-reachable I think it may depend
on the language but that's kind of the
the uh General framework and of course
the Grand Challenge is to do a trial of
NP I don't think actually this will go
take us that far but hopefully we'll get
more than what we've got here okay thank
you
[Applause]
okay so
[Music]
um
is